ça va partir pour deux minutes isabelle
contre benjamin roure agissent également
chez vous on va démarrer dans 3 2 à la
mettez le derrière
c'est parti comme chez moi aussi je le
trouve sympathique d'habitude à lhassa
je connais que je côtoie mais
honnêtement en animations ça va pas dans
la posture ça va pas dans la voie ça va
pas il présente un show genou il forme
les publics ne l'emmène jamais il est
trés toujours assez mal à l'aise face à
place honnêtement quand tu le vois moi
j'aime j'ai mal à mon animation
j'ai mal à ma france à moi mon intérieur
que ça me choque ça me choque parce
qu'il est certes dans l'empathie laisse
des petites phrases c'est c'est toujours
des bébés des lieux communs il n'y a
rien d'extraordinaire il emmène rien
franchement il ne se passe rien c'est le
degré zéro pour mettre de l'animation ça
ne me convainc pas et c'est vrai alors
vous allez me dire ah il est beau tout
est résumé tu me dis ah il a un beau cul
travaux pour animer ne sert à quoi
d'avoir m'occupe pas grand chose certes
être beau ça sert mais ce n'est pas une
car donateurs ne soit mathieu oui mais
ça continue après il va vous soutenir
dans votre spécialité c'est de vous
racketter mais faut quand même arrêter
cinq minutes à ce que vous avez même pas
de ramasser j'ai un cdi
justement je me suis souvenu que je vais
assez des deux journalistes donc a
priori j'enquête est précisément j'ai
fait ce que vous n'avez pas fait j'ai
enquêté
je rejette toutes les prestations de
david ginola depuis 2000 16000 et dans
incroyable talent jusqu'à aujourd'hui
alors effectivement dans la première
sélection dans la première année il
avait l'air d'avoir avalé un manche à
balai il était complètement a mis le nez
et il ne dégageait pas grand chose
contrairement à vous souvent mais la
balle est déjà nettement mieux créer la
troisième saison il est vraiment dégagé
en plus vous n'avez définitivement rien
compris parce que son rôle ce n'est pas
de faire le show et de plaies au public
ou aux téléspectateurs à qui vous
voudrez son premier boulot et c'est pour
ça qu'à que sept minutes c'est de
décontracter les candidats et de
s'occuper d'eux et de les gérer et ça il
le fait très très bien de plus
pardonnez-moi mais l'aspect esthétique
compte aussi il a effectué un petit clip
promener comme cyril le jarret musclé ça
compte aussi pour les femmes
si vous aviez sont regarnis aurait déjà
cinquante danseurs du boulot mais je
vous dise lui il est en nette
progression et toi tu l'invaincu
[Applaudissements]
très bon état qui vous a convaincu
mondiale a rien à dire en tout cas lui a
mis une mise à je suis pas sûr qu on
voit benjamin coisy dans le bas des
mises à mal à parler plus longtemps mais
il a quand même
alors oui alors oui alors ça alors il a
en mars compense les des tweetos et pour
finir la question et ts animateurs on
n'a pas dit s qu'il a progressé will a
progressé mais partait de la redresser
voilà c'est fini c'est fini c'est fini
et bien en tout cas alors à bon rythme
et oui tout de suite
voilà
[Applaudissements]
les radars